oh [__] God damn it just it just slides
right on we got a glue them on
Jesus
first of all uh congrats on everything I
feel like I feel like you were just on
the show not long ago but dude yeah I
think like a few months ago a few months
ago for sure a few months ago
I go through them you've been dropping
some good music lately for sure lots of
[__] singles getting played on the
radio yeah it is going up is it I feel
like you've always had
like record sales you've always you've
gotten plaques as a kid like but is it a
little different now when you like
wherever you go you hear your [__] on
the radio because I feel like
do it again is like
right the most successful radio record
you've had it is it's my first one so
like um it's my first walk them down was
one but do it again do it again it's
like everywhere Rhythm radio Urban rate
like it's everywhere so this is like new
it's still a new feeling so I I'm
enjoying it every time I hear it on the
radio like um I turned it all the way up
I'm enjoying it because it was times I
used to be like man I'm never on the
radio but now I'm finally on the radio
so I'm grateful for it yeah it's like
crazy too because like you're kind of
like you're you're so young but you're
kind of like like lightweight OG now man
yeah for sure
but the success I had yeah hey so for
the people in the comments we're gonna
speculate what happened with your chin
because we don't want people to think
you got you you uh you went you know
face person is the wrong thing you know
I don't know man I just be breaking that
sometime me too
as long as it's not the wrong breakout
you know so yeah for sure
for you you're obviously uh one of the
faces of Memphis Yeah so and you are
someone who we've watched kind of grow
into like to me one of the more mature
like well-grounded like centered artists
in rap like I feel like you kind of went
from being like somebody who you never
knew what kind of [__] you'd be wrapped
up in when we'd open the phone so now
you're always spreading positivity
what would be advice you would give John
Morant right now John Moran um just
pretty much know like
all the things like that must happen for
you to grow and you know for you to be
more grateful
for for the occupation at hand you know
what I'm saying we gotta face adversary
adversity sometimes to realize you know
the power we hold and how good life is
for us and how much God loves us so you
know that's just God sending a storm his
way so he can learn something from it
and once he learned it he gonna bounce
back stronger than ever because you're
no stranger to like late night IG lives
that you probably regret yeah
I mean it's a pretty long yeah uh so
yeah I just think like I think a lot of
people are being hard on the dude it's
like they're used to kid at the end of
the day you know what I'm saying yeah
for sure man